نحن الان على متن مروحيه تابعه للقوات
التركيه تحاول ايصال المساعدات الى
المناطق النائيه التي ضربها الزلزال يمكن
من النافذه معاينه التضاريس الصعبه لهذه
المنطقه اي احد سيعاني في محاوله الوصول
الى هذه المناطق
جبال شاهقه مكسوه بالثلوج لذا فالوصول الى
هنا مهمه صعبه فما بالكم بهذه الكميه من
المساعدات الناس في المناطق المحيطه
طالبوا في الايام الماضيه على منصه
التواصل بارسال مساعدات الى هذه المنطقه
من قوه التركيه تعمل جاهده لايصال
المساعدات الى هؤلاء الناس المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال تبلغ مساحتها مساحه دوله
كامله وعدد المتضررين هنا يتجاوز عدد سكان
الدوله كامله كذلك هذه معاناه لكل من يريد
المساعده هذه قريه اخرى ضربها الزلزال
سكانها يناشدون للمساعده في هذه المروحيه
مساعدات متنوعه من ملابس واغذيه بالنسبه
لهؤلاء الجنود هذه ليست مجرده مهمه عسكريه
هذه عائلاتهم التي تحتاج الى مساعده لذلك
كثير من التوتر والعمل تحت الضغط النفسي
الهائل بالنسبه لهؤلاء الجنود